[Musik]
so liest
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
weihnachtsbäckerei diese woche gibt es
von mir eine leckere weihnachtliche
torte aber die können wir natürlich
nicht nur zu weihnachten machen
sie können zum beispiel auch schon zur
adventszeit machen oder auch einfach mal
so im winter wenn sich max richtig super
lecker sie hat sich den hintern mit drin
also ein bisschen fruchtig aber auch
schön cremig und sah nicht durch eine
mascarpone creme und diese torte nennt
sich schnee torte weil wir nämlich
obendrauf noch leckere pc stückchen
haben und dass sie dann auf sie sind
schöne schneelandschaft
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten für den biskuit teig ich mache
jetzt einen mit mandeln wenn ihr zb eine
glutenfreie torte machen wollt könnt ihr
auch einfach meinen biscuit boden von
meiner raffaello torte nehmen die war
nämlich glutenfreie war kein mehr drin
war und ich werde jetzt aber heute einen
normalen biss gezeigt machen mit ein
bisschen mandeln ich brauche dafür 430
und zucker 100 gramm mehl 40 g
speisestärke 50 gramm mandeln die habe
ich schon fein gemahlen das war jetzt
welche ohne haut 40 gramm butter die es
schon verlassen und bisschen abgekühlt
eine prise salz und drei viertel
teelöffel backpulver und falls ihr euch
fragt wie ich drei viertel teelöffel
backpulver hinbekommen ich habe hier
einfach meinem esslöffel und hab da
einen viertel und einen halben teelöffel
und kann dass man eben nicht ganz exakt
abmessen
ich habe jetzt hier meinen back rahmen
darin werde ich jetzt gleich den teig
backen und habe den auf 26 cm
eingestellt und damit der bak habe nicht
ausläuft muss man dem jetzt vorher
investiert papier einwickeln machen auch
die content also da kann man einfach
sichergehen dass da nichts rauskommt
und diesen bug rahmens stelle ich jetzt
hier einfach auf mein back hofft zwar
mit wachs folie darunter aber die
feuchte man jetzt gar nicht mal ja das
papier jetzt im rahmen dessen das kann
ich jetzt dastehen lassen und werde
jetzt den teig zubereiten und bei mir
wird es jetzt keine sauerteig weil ich
heute möchte dass die torte nicht zu
hoch wird sondern eher ein bisschen
flach wird und wenn ihr einen hohen teil
haben wollt könnte auch einfach ein
bisschen mehr davon nehmen und die menge
mit auf sechs eier einfach hochrechnen
jetzt kommen die eier einfach in die
rührschüssel rein da kommt der zucker
mit dazu und das wird jetzt richtig
schön cremig gerührt das kann fünf bis
zehn minuten dauern
[Applaus]
und die eier masse ist fertig wenn ich
hier den schneebesen reinstecken und da
läuft einfach nicht mehr runter dann ist
so richtig schön halb zwölf sozusagen
ich habe zwar noch vergessen die prise
salz dazugeben
die geben wir auch vielleicht mal mit
dazu und wer möchte kann den tag auch
noch ein bisschen aufpimpen mit etwas
aroma als ich nehme hier etwas vanille
ist es denn ein fachmann dänemark aus
der schote direkt und das ist in öl
eingelegt also nicht in alkohol und das
finde ich eben gut weil man sich da
einfach keine gedanken darum machen muss
er wegen dem alkohol wegen kindern und
da gebe ich jetzt ganz wenig nur dazu
das ist nämlich sehr hoch konzentriert
und das riecht auch richtig lecker nach
vanille und wer möchte kann dann noch
etwas wie tamandl aroma dazu geben das
sind diese kleinen fläschchen die man im
supermarkt bekommt und da nehme ich
jetzt so ein halbes fläschchen gebe ich
dazu das passt super zu den mandeln und
gibt einfach dieses schöne mandler roma
jetzt gebe ich das mehl einmal durch den
sie gemeinsam mit der speisestärke damit
wir keine klümpchen bekommen und wir in
schönen glatten teig haben da auch noch
das backpulver mit dazu und einmal kurz
durch 7
und jetzt einmal kurz unterhalten ganz
vorsichtig damit wir keine luft jetzt
wieder aus der masse heraus schlagen und
den teig streichen
und dann gebe ich jetzt die mandeln mit
dazu sie sind jetzt schön fein gemahlen
und auch die flüssige butter die jetzt
eben abgekühlt sein sollte
das gericht später noch viel besser weil
nämlich die füllung auch richtig
aromatisch wird und würzig wird da kommt
nämlich ein bisschen sind mit rein
ja hat durch durch die fis bittermandel
aroma rechts nach amaretto weil amaretto
und wenn man zum beispiel auch ein
tiramisu mit mandel liter macht kann man
eigentlich auch dieses bittermandel
aroma nehmen und hat es dann einfach
alkoholfrei also vom aroma ist wirklich
so das gleiche und will das dann
tatsächlich untergehoben habt könnt ihr
das in die vorbereitete form einfüllen
und ihr seht es ist ein richtig schöner
lockerer teig und wie gesagt wenn ihr
den teig höher haben wollt einfach auf
sechs eier hochrechnen
so stand main standard bis betrifft
natürlich ohne die mandeln und das ist
wirklich sehr lecker sehr saftig und
heute eben noch aromatisch sowie datei
gibt es 175 grad ober und unterhitze für
etwa 28 bis 30 minuten gebacken bei mir
brauche etwa 28 minuten es kann
natürlich sein dass er ein paar minuten
länger oder kürzer braucht der ofen muss
auf jeden fall vorgeheizt sein und
danach lassen wir den teig einfach mal
abkühlen
mein tag ist jetzt gebacken und ich habe
ihn jetzt hier auf dem abkühlen gitter
gegeben damit er einfach abkühlen kann
und ihr seht hier das ungefähr vier
zentimeter hoch so drei bis vier und den
werde ich dann später in dünne scheiben
schneiden aber wie gesagt wer möchte
dass ein dicker wird nimmt die große
menge und ich werde den jetzt mit einer
leckeren hinterfüllung füllen und dann
noch mit mascarpone creme
wir werden jetzt erst mal die
hinterfüllung vorbereiten weil die
gleich noch abkühlen muss und dafür
zeige ich euch jetzt die zutaten
wir brauchen 350 gramm himbeeren ich
habe es natürlich tief gefrorene und ups
ist schon eine weile draußen stehen
damit es ein bisschen anschauen können
hier habe ich 200 mm saft da habe ich
jetzt meinen kirschsaft genommen weil
ich gestern kirschen aus dem glas hatte
aber ihr könnt irgendwelchen saft
etwas vanille aroma oder wiederwahlen
extrakt hier habe ich wieder dieses
bittermandel ihr könnt aber auch vier
esslöffel amaretto zudem sagt peter zu
geben
dann brauchen wir ein bisschen
zimtstange für den geschmack eine
zitrone
das ist natürlich eine biotonne dafür
brauchen wir gleich die schale 30 gramm
zucker und 25 gramm stärke das erste was
ich jetzt mache ist den saft aufkochen
aber ich lass mir so ein bisschen saft
hier drin übrig da gebe ich nämlich
jetzt gleich die stärke dazu und
verrührt die nämlich damit damit sie
später einfach keine klümpchen bildet
wenn ich sie dann eben zum restlichen
saft dazu geben und es wird jetzt kurz
verrührt
da kann ich das hier einfach mal kurz
stehen lassen und jetzt gebe ich hier zu
meinem saft und bisschen vanille dazu
ich hab so ein bisschen
dann den stangen
und den zitronenschalen abrieb der muss
natürlich nicht sein aber ich finde da
macht es ganz so ein bisschen frischer
und passt einfach perfekt zu den zimt
und zum bittermann auch immer und jetzt
muss das ganze noch aufgekocht werden
mache ich jetzt einmal auf höchster
stufe
dann gebe ich noch bis jetzt
wintermantel aroma dazu da könnte
einfach zu viel nehmen die ihr möchtet
entweder wieder ein halbes fläschchen
oder nur ein paar tropfen und zum saft
kommt jetzt auch noch eine zucker dazu
und jetzt müssen wir einfach mal kurz
partner dürfte hierzu 23 minuten kochen
und jetzt nämlich die zimtstange wieder
raus die haben jetzt schönes aroma an
den saft abgegeben und es riecht richtig
lecker weihnachtlich ihren klubs und
jetzt gebe ich da diese stärke schon
dazu
was es jetzt nochmal auf brauchen damit
die stärke jetzt binden kann
ihr seht auch schon sobald das kopf
findet die stärke und es wird so ein
fester vor den und barg gebe ich jetzt
noch zum schluss die hindern mit rein
die sind jetzt bei mir noch ein bisschen
kalt und dadurch kühlt dann eben auch
dieser pudding ganz schnell ab jetzt
wechsel ich ganz kurz auf einem löffel
kann jetzt auch bisher die hitze
unternehmen und das ganze einfach kurz
verrühren
so das war's jetzt auch schon wir lassen
das jetzt einfach ein bisschen abkühlen
bevor wir es dann auf die torte geben
und in dieser zeit kann ich schon mal
meinen tortenboden durchschneiden
ich sehe jetzt zum durchschneiden der
1000 blüten einfachsten trotten säge und
hab da 22 drehte drinnen das heißt ich
kann gleich den kuchen in zwei bzw 3 auf
dünne böten schneiden und habe jetzt
einfach den abstand so ausgemessen dass
die böden ungefähr gleich dick werden
wobei jemand darauf achten müssen dass
unten der boden immer etwas dicker
bleibt jetzt schneide ich das hier
einfach hier durch und da geht auch
besser wenn der teig schon tag alt ist
aber ich ab verarbeitet es frisch weiter
ich habe ihn einfach richtig gut
durchführen lassen und abkühlen lassen
und dann klappt es eben auch frisch der
browser dann zwar ein bisschen aber das
ist jetzt nicht weiter schlimm
morath nächste ja auch dazu ich merke
dass schon netto richtigen fleck
gekommen ist weiß ich lehne diese sehen
unter der bei uns schon ein bisschen
wäre also letztlich haben wir sollten
keinen schlägt und dieses jahr das ist
dass wir uns richtig schöne weiße
weihnachten
wir haben gewohnt mein manager
schwarzwälder ich glaube auch noch nicht
ski fahren
ich war wahrscheinlich die schneekugel
die dann im urlaub aber das stimmt
mehr möchte ich uns anschließen ich habe
jetzt übrigens in der zwischenzeit vor
lauter reden
ich habe jetzt den boden auf eine schöne
tortenplatte gesetzt ich selbst jetzt
ausweis weil ich es später möchte dass
meine worte auf eine weitere platte ist
soll der bitte nach schnee aussehen wenn
wir hier noch keinen schnee haben und
sie zwei anderen habe ich einfach mit
diesen torten retter an drogen und lasst
sie jetzt einfach kurz an der seite
stehen auf den teig gebe ich jetzt meine
wer mich schon drauf
[Musik]
die wird dann gleich noch ein bisschen
fester wenzel abkühlt aber ich mache das
jetzt so wie bei meiner schwarzwälder
kirschtorte dass ich jetzt nicht bis zur
komplett zum rand raus streiche sondern
so 12 cm am rand platz lassen damit sie
außen einfach nicht rot wird soll ich
will dass die später außen ganz weiß
bleibt und es gebe ich jetzt erstmal in
den kühlschrank für ungefähr eine halbe
stunde bis es etwas fest ist und ganz
abgekühlt ist
und danach kommt nur noch die sonne
drauf und dann kann man es auch gleich
geschafft
ich habe jetzt eine halbe stunde
gewartet und mein kurven ist jetzt schön
kalt die kirchen kirschen zeigen schon
die himbeeren sind kalt und jetzt werde
ich doch die sahne zu bereiten und darf
er brauche ich hier 300 gramm sahne die
ist jetzt richtig schön kalt 500 gramm
meisterkrone 150 gramm quark dass ich
jetzt in magerquark hier habe ich 50
gramm puderzucker und ich benutze
bislang apart susanne staaten und ihr
könnt natürlich auch relative oder
aktive benutzen
aber dann wird die creme einfach nicht
sofort fest und ihr habt noch ein
bisschen länger wartezeit so etwa drei
bis vier stunden und mit seiner tat ist
einfach so da kann ich die cremes sofort
weiter benutzen und sogar den kuchen
gleich ansteigen also das findet immer
super und für die deko brauche ich so
ein paar bugs die habe ich jetzt bereit
schon in der tüte drin da brauche ich
etwa 100 gramm kann aber auch sein dass
ein bissle mehr oder ein bisschen
weniger brauchen
ich nehme jetzt hierzu erst mal meine
sahne und nehmen das saunapark und ja
wie gesagt nämlich das immer gerne mal
schnell fest wird ohne sich natürlich
halt auch vegan also das kann einfach
jeder benutzen
gleich zweimal sah nicht mehr zugänglich
vegetarisch und davon nehme ich jetzt
etwa drei teelöffel
[Musik]
für die saale aber ich muss erst mal
ganz groß auf zusagen und jetzt kann das
warm up mit rein einfach drei teelöffel
[Musik]
und einfach fest und zur stadt schlagen
die sahne ist schön fest kann ich sogar
umkippen und fliegt raus und jetzt werde
ich noch jemand starb ohne creme
zusammenrühren mascarpone ist ja so ein
bisschen fester ist natürlich auch sehr
kritisch aber eben auch schön cremig das
darf man nicht zu lange ruhe und sonst
wie christlich eben durch den durch das
wetter war zwar drin ist und falls sie
aber keiner mascarpone habt oder sie
nicht nötig könnte auch einfach die
meisterkrone komplett durch den quark
ersetzen dadurch wird die torte ein
bisschen leichter und schmeckt auch sehr
lecker ist schwer so richtung käse sahne
und mag ich eigentlich auch ganz ehrlich
quarkcreme aber die mascarpone macht es
einfach super cremig da kommt jetzt
quark mitteilen
der lok hat das ist so ein bisschen auf
dann gebe ich hier auch drei teelöffel
seiner partnerin einfach damit die creme
schön fest wird und uns später nicht
verläuft wobei durch die mascarpone
dürft auch gar nicht verlaufen aber
nicht einschüchtern
und dann bleibt sie eben auch nach dem
anschluss und west und jetzt noch der
puderzucker denen hier und denen sich
einmal kurz hierdurch 7
und da könnt ihr auch entscheiden wie
süß ihr dasselbe haben wollt als ihr
könnt da gerne etwas weniger puderzucker
nehmen oder etwas mehr
ihr müsst hand auch beachten dass
lammert schon so leicht süß ist also
falls ihr ein anderes bindemittel nehmen
müsste einfach nur bislang zucker
dazugeben und jetzt wird das noch kurz
verrührt das reicht auch schon und ihr
seht es sich auch wirklich eine ziemlich
feste creme
und da habe ich jetzt einfach noch die
sonne unter
das mache ich jetzt auch zwei portionen
sie habe jetzt meinen schönen durch
gekühlten boden und legten eine
springform rand außenrum beziehungsweise
importen brand sodass sind einfach meine
bank haben die ich zu hause habe und da
gebe ich jetzt ungefähr ein drittel der
saane drauf ganz vorsichtig und
verstreicht das mit so einer kleinen
winkel palette da muss man ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein damit man da diese im
erfüllung jetzt nicht so selbst gesetzt
und nach außen streicht und jetzt setzt
sich da den einen boden drauf aber ich
nehme da jetzt nicht den mittleren
sondern den oberen damit ich einfach
oben einen schönen abschluss hat gleich
das auch ziemlich dünn und ich habe mit
den tortenring hier übrigens nicht außen
rum weil die creme eben läuft sondern
ich möchte einfach aus einem schönen
abschluss haben aber falls er keinen
tortenring habt ist nicht schlimm also
bei dem ritter braucht man es nicht
falls ihr mit seiner papa arbeitet jetzt
nehme ich dann noch mal ein drittel und
verstreicht es wieder und dann kommt der
letzte boden
jetzt lasse ich hier nur ein ganz
bisschen was von der creme übrig damit
ihr das gleich auch an den rand der
traute verstreichen kann und ich kann
jetzt sofort den torten bringen abnehmen
weil ich ja mit seiner partei erarbeitet
habe also falls ihr jetzt mit aquino
oder gelatine gearbeitet habt müsst ihr
die torte natürlich vorher erstmal 30
vier stunden kühlen
dieses fest ist und so sieht sie dann
aus und jetzt werde ich noch den rand
der torte mit der restlichen creme
bestreichen
[Musik]
so ich habe in trier torte gerd
gestrichen und jetzt kommen noch diese
bw pvs oben drauf aber die muss ich
jetzt vorher mit dem nudelholz klein
machen und deswegen habe ich ja auch in
seiner tüte drin die ich oben
verschlossen habe damit einfach jetzt
nichts rauskommt heller die ein bisserl
herzklopfen und die müssen jetzt auch
nicht alle klein sein wir wollen ja so
ein bisschen kleine und große
schneekugeln so und ich habe mich ja ich
habe mir jetzt hier schon eine
tortenplatte auf so ein kleines tablett
gelegt ich glaube es etwas größer sein
können damit ich das einfach jetzt
gleich auffangen kann
und jetzt lassen jetzt einfach auf die
torte schneiden
das neue fag weil du dich mit einem
videoprogramm nicht auskennen ich mache
jetzt halt einen echten schloss er sich
nun aus aber nicht das aussehen dieser
kunstschnee auf meiner trottel
meine tochter ist steht er jetzt alt und
ist schon fertig aber ich mache das noch
ein bisschen deko drauf und zwar habe
ich mich hier nicht einig gebührten
passte genommen also so in zucker teig
mit zellulose pulver mit cmc und es wird
dann eben fest und daraus möchte ich
jetzt nicht so ein paar schneekristalle
ausstechen und rollt es jetzt einfach
dünn auf becker stärke aus aber auch
einfach etwas vornehmen und dann eben
etwas 10.10 uhr eintreten dann wird es
aussehen
jetzt nehme ich mich hier meine
weihnachts aussteller diese schnee und
eiskristalle und kann jetzt damit hier
einfach so wißler ausstechen
so und dann haben diese aus werfer und
dann kann ich das einmal aus werfen
und das sehe ich jetzt erstmal kann
dieser regen dann haben sie noch so ein
schönes muster drauf und zwar drückt man
dann einfach wissen fester und alessa
strukturiert und ich nehme jetzt noch
hier dieses kristall pulver meine pulver
farbe das hat seinen leichten weißen
schimmer und damit bekommt diese
schneeflocke wird noch ungern an das
wahnsinnig viele blinde ich lasse es
diese sterne ganz gut trocknen und
selbst wird dann auf meine torte und
mein mann kann hier also tat ich es
jetzt diese hübschen schneeflocken
einfach nur hier auf meine torte drauf
und klar sieht man die jetzt nicht so
gewinnt ihr droht werden aber ich will
ja auch das ist eine weiße beutel ist
und das muss eben genau
und jetzt kann ich die karte direkt an
schneiden damit darauf achten dass ihr
euch ein besserer küchenpapier nehmen
daran liegt weil ja ihnen drohte ist und
jetzt einfach einmal durch und jetzt das
messer sauber machen sonst haben wir
nämlich die torte nicht mehr so schön
weiß sondern obendrauf roth
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach raus holen
guckt euch mal das schöne stück in der
mitteilung mit dem roten sofa murat kann
denn aufpasst probiere ich jetzt einfach
die torte
mit kiwi könnte man die tore aufmachen
mit kiwi muss man nur aufpassen wenn man
mit gelatine arbeitet da wirkt die
gelatine dann nicht mehr als okay wie
muss man doch immer aufkochen und
speziell bearbeiten weil da diese säure
drin ist auch bei anders kann man
natürlich machen aber ich finde es mit
den beiden echt perfekt ist ein richtig
leckere trottel
ja
die ich auch gar nicht schwer richtig
leichte torte diese himbeeren haben so
eine bitte so ein bisschen säure hat
leichtem ton bisschen von der zitrone
und dann einfach diese leckere macht das
ohne creme das passt perfekt dazu
und die bw tipps die die machen ist
locker und leicht als wird man süßen
schnell bestätigt ganz in der früh weg
gibt es zum nachlesen auf kellys -
blog.de
ihr könnt mir mal gerne eure
abwandlungen schreiben also ob ihr das
jetzt mit kirschen macht oder nur team
bern oder mit anderen früchten natürlich
wird auch in apfel gut dazupassen grad
zu diesem sind und vielleicht mit
bislang als kämmerin oder muskat ich
finde es echt perfekt mit dem hinweis
ich bin halt auch im bett und ich freue
mich natürlich wenn ihr die torte nach
macht und sie mir dann auch facebook
oder instagram schickt also foto ihr
könnt mir auch eine methode
vorbeischicken dass ich auch okay und
ich freue mich dann einfach aufs nächste
mal wieder
und ja dann sehen wir uns ganz bald
so weit nichts zu tun wie sofort kalt
war schon ordentlich gegeben
[Musik]
übrigens findet ihr alle vor
benutzt habe auch bei mir im shop auf
zehn.de und ich wünsche euch jetzt einen
noch eine richtig schöne besinnliche
weihnachtszeit genießt die zeit mit
euren freunden mit eurer familie bis
bald